so I will also call a my distinguished
other panelists first Leila Kenny can
you join us also here in the the table
and so your and the you're also the
co-director of the cast but you know so
the executive director of the Arts
Initiative yeah it's a radical stage
here be careful yeah the executive
director of the Arts Initiative at the
MIT you're trained as an historian but
use embrace a lot of different topics
including architecture social issues
media issues and I think it's very
interesting had this vision abuts that
the feel that we embrace then we have
some ha well we remember an
anthropologist and I have a background
in communication and you're a director
of art partner ten years of experience
and artists meeting scientists we have
so I've just go in the Wrights names you
he clapping he's not with us
he just got a call he sent an email it's
not the Covey they told us but he said
coming here with a no wouldn't be fun
and so he says at home in Portland II
and we have a so Nicola over for sweet
snacks so it's sweet snacks is a kind he
will show us is a kind of a consulate
for art science and technology is a
creator has been a creator of many
projects in different fields underground
major institution like luma and and
others also writer of different books
and and and papers we have Ellen van van
from the University of Bordeaux head of
the science cultural and science probe
other science you have a master in
cultural project conception with a
special orientation and social and
politics so I think it's good about
innovation to reach the audience not
just for product but for the society in
general and so we have smart printer you
have five minutes you know that
everything is timed really well just
Cala come with us I apply for the starts
price now I'm dead I did not apply so
Cala who's a project manager has thought
surprised working a lot it's it's not
that you could came to us because it's
the high season on the other prize so
thank you very for joining us and you
absolutely need to go to our to answer
electronic artists and during the
festival it's so amazing especially with
all the new space downstairs it's a it's
an incredible journey so we'll start the
presentation to be sure that in the
rites list because he stressed me that I
must be absolutely in the rotten name so
its first some huh so I'll let you
present what is your art partner
initiative yes good morning so two years
ago I was in a leadership program it's
called think School of Creative
leadership I think many of you would
really love it and I was in this group
of about 30 people worldwide from
foundations bio tech arts everything and
in the second module we were working
together on a project in fashion and in
the second module I noticed something
and a small group of our class was
getting really nervous they started to
pitch it they started to push a little
harder they started to ask questions as
where does this lead to
what's the structure how's the process
and I realized that they were in
desperate need of structure so I started
to look around and I saw that of my
classmates most of these people were
from corporates from tech or from
science and it's it's in I think it's
called the sensing phase and I think
most of us would call it the artistic
research face and I was quite
comfortable in not knowing where we were
headed but I felt then and there that
these clients of these people these
classmates actually represented many of
my clients so I founded our partner 11
years ago with my husband Robert and we
work with 50 artists in over 50
companies in hundreds of projects
interventions small ones big ones
interventions of a day projects of over
five years for six years but it was at
that moment that I became conscious of
this inner world of my clients so this
picture was taken by one of our artists
a long time ago for a daughter and I
think all of them wanted to go somewhere
my clients want to go somewhere and they
realized that the way they've been going
there is not the way for the project
they're in or the questions they're
standing for or the vision they want to
reach what they really want is a
different perspective somebody to take
them on a different road to go on a
different trail they really want
different views they definitely do not
want change consultants at that moment
or change experts or problem solvers
they really know what they do not want
they want confuse disruptors they really
crave for creativity and for imagination
and which they never say but we really
want is curiosity and attention and they
want people to be really curious about
their jobs so they invite these artists
in and they are completely ready to go
they are ready for a new journey but
they're used to climbing the stairs
step-by-step and they know in their
minds that they should trust the process
but they get agitated fidgeting and
somewhere along they start to doubt the
process and they want structure and they
need it and the irr list many of you
will recognizes it's very comfortable in
not knowing is exploring different parts
and different routes they go one way
they go the other way they find out they
are blocked they will find another way
and they might sometimes lose the people
on the stairs so I realized that this is
how my clients feel
and usually they do not have a rope so
that leaves us to act on this on this us
s intermediate as myself but also the
artist realizing that this is on the
mind of the people they work with they
might not tell you but if you are really
if you look you will read the signs and
we did a research with the judge
University of Applied Sciences the
article was just published in the
holland management review so therefore
not to be shared but to be bought in two
months time it will be free I'm sure and
it's not enough time to go into detail
but we asked 30 organizations and 30
artists what would make a successful
collaboration and these were six of the
things that were coming back to us Trust
trust in an unknown process in an
unknown outcome prep and briefing the
preparation and the briefing as Greg
where's Greg yeah yesterday told us a
lot of it is about managing the project
common goals clarity on practical stuff
money time oh that all that kind of
can't say it here but also casting the
creative team opening up to the artists
mindset it is about the quality of the
creatives and the clients told us that
they they really want to have that new
perspective the imagination the
confusing part but there's also
qualities of organizations making room
for experiment and I think someone said
said it before space for employees for
example if you are in a concern see or a
law firm or a tech firm that's based on
hourly rates for
for their clients and they cannot spend
the hours it won't work so you have to
make time for that I'm really almost
ready and then to find common ground a
big yes to the experiment and a process
of co-creation so what does this mean
for innovation I am pretty sure that if
people feel like this there will be no
innovation so we need to make sure that
we meet somewhere and that we actually
actually know of each others worlds and
each other's excitation wishes and we go
for the same dream and then Tilly
yesterday said we should be more human
and more humane and in nobody none of
our clients ever asks for it but in all
the projects about innovation or change
it's all about humanizing the corporate
or the organizational context that's
what the artists do even in the process
of innovation thank you thank you very
much so now we'll move to Nicola Ruffo
from Swiss snacks so here you are we a
little war of innovation also art and
technology and it's nice place yes but
my experience so far before I came to
San Francisco got this call is more into
urbanization contemporary art film as
well so I'm actually a writer journalist
not an engineer and I got a call like
two and a half years ago to fill this
position I went with two suitcases and
so here I am here at the pier it's the
pier in San Francisco next to it is the
Exploratorium it's a 50 years old
Science Museum which is also very good
to have them as a neighbor and
as you told already it's kind of 15
years years old experiment for
Switzerland it's kind of innovation now
post kind of science embassy it's always
kind of complicated to explain the model
and usually when I present as with
snakes I go so if you have kind of a
Flickr account with all the new pictures
of our event and so I just stuck in the
plane when preparing this presentation
with this picture of an event and it
actually describes quite well Swiss next
it's kind of black box over there and it
depends a bit on the perspective on how
you want to tell the story of Swiss
snacks I see it kind of as a tool box so
we have a lot of different partners
maybe I should explain a bit out also
our funding model so we are a
public-private partnership so we have 30
percent of our funding comes through the
Secretary of innovation education and
research and 70 percent so we have grown
over this 15 years comes from all these
partners here so we work with startups
with different programs universities
artists designers through the mandate
with the Swiss art council and okay of
course we have also other companies like
for example the SP bee-eaters the Swiss
National Railway is also in our
co-working space as one example and then
we have as well we work with foundation
more like when we have like a project or
another residency we want to fund yeah
of course innovators as well and so we
are kind of
a network decentralized network with the
red dots these are Swiss Snax offices so
there are five offices one in Boston
near MIT one in Rio Sao Paulo this is
actually one in Brazil one in Bangalore
India and one in Shanghai and the rest
there are signs like the technology
offices in embassies they are also part
of our network we meet once a year and
we have also a monthly exchange about
project but the specifics of our program
or mostly site site-specific on any
location has their own programming their
own mandate so we have at the pier I
think our the special thing about the
Swiss next San Francisco is that we have
a lot of space we have a big gallery we
have a conference space we have a
co-working space and so this helps us to
also find the right format if we invite
artists and designers so we do kind of
accelerator programs with with them we
are doing as well exhibitions with them
now we just have an exhibition with
melody musei and we also partner with
other institutions as well from the
Swiss snack Network so not far from here
is the sound guilty head Swiss and we
have this exhibition it just closed now
but we had this exhibition together with
them melody Musa is a virtual reality
artist she developed a piece where you
can experience this as a multiplayer and
it's kind of a landscape with a lot of
hands so you're it's kind of a desert
and you're building hands together hand
sculptures and so it was pretty
interesting to see as well bit Paris how
it grew so of course when it was night
here in Paris people were
growing sculptures and 10v when you were
coming in there in the morning and San
Francisco into the gallery you have seen
kind of new sculptures in this landscape
so yeah that's kind of an example how we
work as well with other institutions
also of course a lot of local
institutions so we are actually never
doing projects alone in in San Francisco
in the Bay Area so we are also
collaborating on exhibitions with
companies like Autodesk we have now a
residency there with the Swiss designers
they are doing non industrial robot
practice and so we are working with
autodesk to with the robotics lab there
I think that's my final slide so we are
also over the year working with
different platforms industry platforms
so actually the next week should have
been the Game Developers Conference is
the big biggest game conference in the
world in San Francisco I had about a big
delegation coming so now everything is
canceled I have a bit more time in in
Paris which is also good but so this is
kind of an example we're also working
like with Sundance the new frontier they
have kind of a storytelling lab so these
are collaborations we are doing since
several years and working with the
institutions together to develop a
meaningful meaningful works that's about
it thank you
thank you thank you very much and if you
have the opportunity to visit the place
it's really worth it so the location is
absolutely beautiful and now we'll move
to Allen's run so tell us about your
initiative in Bordeaux hello thanks for
inviting me I'm my lunchtime I'm in
charge of the art and science program
for the University of Bordeaux you can
see a picture of one of our residences
it's seeing the innovation so I choose
the picture and just it is important for
me to introduce you my University first
because the the particularity is that I
work for an innovation department art
and science program is part of
innovation the department and it means
something in a new University and
because the University of Bordeaux is a
large multidisciplinary
multidisciplinary University because
these know it's Marie's 53,000 students
father is an academic and one of the
main thing is that we and it's really
important is that we don't have any
finite faculty you know University so
for the art and science program is
basically a visiting artists program
just to present you in few words my
departments and my office it's we are
dealing with one objective is out to
intensify innovation and we have two
different offices one which is in charge
of transferring innovation with
companies and my office is really about
creates new opportunities I will explain
you a little bit later the objective
that the office is ready to design new
program that are relevant for the inner
innovation system basically for us as a
huge University
breaking down the university silos is
really the beginning of kind of
innovation just to make people work
together and create something and the DG
art and science program is really about
that it's really about working with our
communities and with the partners as
well as artists to talk a little bit
more about the program the purpose of
the program is really about stimulating
creativity we have a call of projects
actually we have two different color
projects one is directly linked to a
festival and the other one is more to
support exploratory projects and to LED
time to
artists and scientists who have a common
project and to build the project
basically my work is really to and
company these these different projects
and it's the the role of the office is
really to create the conditions with the
support is really to create the
condition of their innovation and up the
creativity and actually it's really
initiating this and to let innovative
bubbles live into the university just
don't be scared just you just to show
why for us what outputs just because
you're we are University I have to count
some indicators from our labs and as you
see we have scientific publication we
have patents application but it's not
the points actually it's kind of side
outputs I I mean I had to create my own
indicators actually because it's really
about creativity by initiating Calibre's
collaboration as I said it requires a
strong support because my role is really
I act as a matchmaker
it's really about the compound
humanizing actors and disciplines how we
can make people from a laboratory for
example in technology and to work with
another laboratory with humanities and
and it's also a lot above about removing
administrative constraints I have to say
and the fact is that we have this
technology technological innovation and
sometimes a beginning of organizational
innovation I remember a scientist who
wanted to have the artist all the
time in the laboratory it's kind of the
beginning of something and just to say
just to sum up and to finish just to say
my point is that my job is really to
create a confident framework to build
relationships about trust that's a huge
challenge itself and just to be there be
there sometimes to see - I don't know to
give some advices as I said before about
where I can publish that or these kind
of things but the main innovation for me
as a university I will for instance I
have a project technological project
about dance and about singing with
technological devices and you know we
have this first stage when it's about
much making and sometimes you have these
artists who have a project and what we
were looking for something and you know
you have this first this first
appointment and the scientist was like
you know arms crossed and what are they
all wanted for me I don't know and
finally we have a festival so one year
later we have this festival in this huge
institutional issue in in Bordeaux and
we found these scientists with this
access code in the cultural center with
this big smile and it was in the other
position and for me was like you know
it's a kind of successful indicators so
we see that even if it's a very serious
framework for creativity it leads to a
really good impact and Kalla so you see
a lot
[Applause]
you see luck a lot of project with a
select Tony can talk to you about one of
the initiatives that our select Roenick
is doing within which is having a
residency program and it's called the
European artificial intelligence lab and
it might make clear some of the
approaches that are electronica has
towards dealing with innovation and
artists and art and science
collaborations so our select ronica has
been oh the clicker thank you sorry has
been dealing with our technology and
science for 40 years and I guess one of
the main questions that ours has always
been posing is how will our future look
like and how do we want our future to
look like especially when you deal with
all this emerging technology how can we
make sure that our humanity doesn't stay
somewhere behind and this is one of the
reasons why we strongly encourage
artists technologists and scientists to
work together because we believe that
art has a very very strong function as a
catalyst for what's happening socially
and in society and they have we believe
that artists can be really sensible to
that and we also believe that these the
outcomes that we see can be really
valuable for policymakers when we decide
how we want our future to in the
legislation legislative way even how we
want to develop technologies especially
within Europe and we have the
possibilities to invite policymakers to
our to all our events that were that
we're making which is really great
so the humanitarian aspect I will keep
really short incredibly important for us
so this is why we funded the first along
a few years ago the European digital art
and science Network that was the ARS
invited
together with a few great corporations
CERN in Switzerland the European Space
Agency and the European Southern
Observatory and later also carnival
Mavis joined as a secret partner mara
more or less to invite artists to join
these corporations and work there and
not throughout one stay but they had
like an initial visit where they would
first meet the people it would cooperate
with then have time to prepare at home
and then come back for a lengthy
residency and then also in the end
present their projects that I was
electronica to reflect about them again
not surprisingly when we evaluated these
residences we came upon the very same
results that Arianna also presented
yesterday and that you in parts and I
mentioned earlier that of course there
is a huge need and trust in in openness
from both partners they both need to be
really willing to understand each
other's work and to dive into the
other's work and also you cannot treat
artists and scientists as a homogeneous
groups because it's very individual
qualities the individual qualities of
artworks that you see and need to
connect to qualities of each scientist
and just as each person is very
individual and of course the wish was
there for a common language which I'm
sure is you can't just create one but
you can try to communicate in a way that
both parties or all three parties
understands depending on how many people
are involved the also big issue in the
outcomes is that we saw a huge potential
in steam education so the results can be
really nicely presented and used in
educational programs and one of our big
big points is that we also want to
strongly involve the public in the
results in showing them because we think
that by educate Amin
educating is such a bad word but like
opening everything to the public they
might want to become curious or want to
delve into these topics themselves so
this is a crucial point in our programs
the engagement of the the public so the
European digital art and science network
has ended but our new project is the
European artificial intelligence lab
which deals with artificial intelligence
and we have 13 European cultural
partners that have opened their doors to
artists and the main points that we have
our educational events we have where we
want to really reach out to the public
networking events of course between all
these different players that come from
various fields of culture and not only
technology and of course the lighthouse
residency programs yes I guess I made
all the important points thank you right
so I must confess that would be totally
biased when a during this round table
because I'm leading the and the founder
of the EPFL a collab it's a design
research lab from the Swiss Federal
Institute of Technology in in Lausanne
we have also artist residency were the
partner of starts residency so we have
also artists in residence but we try
really to bring new technology and see
how we can bring meaning to this
technology how can study so the
perception of the end users and so it's
why we're really focusing on innovation
and usually as I said at the beginning
but there's a bit more people right now
innovation usually it's kind of a
dangerous word here and and I fully
understand because there's this
dangerous issue of lack of freedom
utilitarian and also another
a lot of art is thought to be a bit fed
about this type of innovation and it was
really worried and now try to get out of
this being forced to work on an
innovation house of freedom regarding
the the technologies and I think it's
it's important for the artists to keep
this freedom but but I need also to be a
bit provocative that's a big question
okay we need to have the whole freedom
for the artists but on the other side
can the artist leave the responsibility
of innovation only to the engineers and
the managers that's I think a big
question
my first background is engineering so I
can be also self critique I think it's
important that we also see what is the
meaning of this new technology what can
we do how it can be embedded in our
daily lives
because it's what really impacts our
idea enough the single thing as I heard
quite often said ok yeah we who are
doing our work but we cannot change the
world so our mission to change the world
I say gosh but there has been movement
including artists that have changed the
world and I was reinterred when you saw
the book of the bear house with one of
the rises that created with this first
link of MIT in fact the bass hundred
years ago what was the the point is that
we had new technology to produce big
walls and concrete new panels of metal
big sheet of glass and what did the
Bauhaus they changed completely a way to
conceive architecture to conceive
objects to think about art and they
create usage of this technology but they
also create meaning for our daily life
with good results bad results but it
changed forever a relation to the built
environment to the inside or the outside
to the materials and so we see that
artists can be really very influential
in the way that we live in our daily
love we had the same change in the in
the late 60s beginning of 70s with all
what was going around the hippie
murderin ISM changing the big industry
of the mill of the computer industry
from the big frame men
big computer - distributed network
exchanging involving reader people and I
think this was also a big change in in
the history so artists can have impact
already laughs in innovation but how and
that's I think that the big question so
I will cite perhaps on one question and
I will general so the panel here in the
middle will be strange position but I
will do it and perhaps the first
questions how artists can see the
innovation what's what's their role in
the process where they need to come in
and I think this is a big big question
perhaps one thing is about when we think
about innovation is there's a lot of
definition one thing for me which is
important is that we think about the new
ideas the creativity but also about the
adoption and that's I think one of the
key thing and innovation it takes the
county at the adoption body users or by
the large audience so so what what is
really the role of their artists in this
in this process I haven't spoke on the
table so I think coming in and asking in
our environment scientists and engineers
to do things they wouldn't otherwise do
one of my favorite examples was the
artist of our strong who came in and
wanted to make a little nano sized
sculpture that he called my mother's
house from the moon
he was Bahamian he took these
photographs lunar photographs of his
mother's house and literally made a
little nano sculpture about besides my
fingernail and he said to the
researchers in the lab it's got to be
pink her house is pink and green they
had never done color on the nano scale
so that became a project and part of the
couple of dissertations in that lab so
that's one thing
thank you I I think it's always in
co-creation so for example we were asked
for the few medical univeristy because
they were not inclusive enough and the
artist she first did her research and
then she gave back all her findings in a
big intervention which is shown online
in a small movie but what happened was
way more interesting after the
intervention students and teachers stood
up and they told the director if we can
discuss this topic in in this honest way
that we want to be a participant and
this led to a five-year co-creation
process where the artist was working
with the students and the teachers on
finding new ways of teaching finding new
entrances for the the practical article
to the practicum the practical teaching
for extracurricular activity so this one
intervention woke them up and by waking
them up people are in an action modus
and then if there's somebody who will
feed into that action modus and actually
support the way that they could changed
the educational system
then we're starting to innovate and it's
not technical innovation but it is very
much innovation and you're in the fields
of music personally so your sewin
practitioner and you see also what is
happening at the academic level how do
you see this in the in the field of more
of music and Sam well again I often see
and we in outside of cast I'm often
having conversations with Berklee School
of Music across the river and trying to
get programs going where coders at MIT
are working with practicing musicians
because I think what happens with a lot
of artists is similar to Leila's example
artists have things they want to do but
we might not necessarily know if it can
be done which is an advantage right
because we're not limited by being
inside the box of the possible but we
don't have the means necessarily to do
it so sometimes the pairings is what
co-creation comes in it turns out there
are lots of things that coders or makers
can do that they don't necessarily know
say a musician or visual artist or a
dancer could find useful so just on that
very practical level if you make these
pairings and get people in the same room
I think that's part of it but I also
like has been very interested in in
watching the exchange with with the lab
I mentioned with Markus Bueller's lab
because they were doing things where
they were they got kind of obsessed with
sonification so they were sana fiying
proteins just to see if they could
extract a certain kind of data or look
at knowledge in a different way from
from that and then at some point I think
some one of the graduate student
musicians they were working with said
well what happen happen if you made a
protein out of music instead so then
they started making synthetic proteins
from sounds and you know that's I don't
think they've come up with anything
particularly useful in that regard but
they've come up but what happens is when
you start generating this is a bit of a
cliche thinking that is not goal driven
or not sort of like hitting a target but
just kind of that the play of ideas
itself is useful artists are familiar
with that in their own ways you know
just strewing ideas about and going okay
this works this works this is crap and
in the lab where everything is so
directed getting labs out of that kind
of directional thinking I think leads to
innovation the protein is not cold cozy
done that's not know the perte is not
cold coffee the nuts not the virus okay
yeah because yeah I also would give an
example which is I think the other way
around it's kind of innovation empowers
the artists so we started a program this
year we just did in in in January for
artists and designers working in
technology who have mostly a practice in
galleries in the art context in design
galleries and they can't make a living
because of the the art market is not of
course buying big robots installations
or at least from from from their point
of the career and so we were working
with them on generating kind of a
revenue model for example a ATP this
these designers working with robotics
buying first generation and robots who
did very automatic tasks and
reprogramming it for gallery exhibitions
for various creative tasks and so they
were in this year that were autodesk
with us and they are now working on a
solution for the film industry with
their robots so they somehow can create
the revenue besides their gallery
practice and i think this could be also
kind of a way which empowers artists to
also have time of the words for for
their artistic practice absalom do you
have also this kind of reverse model
anyway just to comment yeah I think
there are less and less border lines
between positions for example I have a
for instance I have
an example of an artist who is actually
the head of networks actually is leading
the innovation process you know I mean
he considers that in the university and
there's a lot of potential contents and
potential people to meet and I think is
really leading the innovation process so
I think it's not only the artist and the
scientist sometimes scientists are I
mean they like that they don't have to
deal with this part of the process and
for me my job is really to take care of
all the process and to be aware if there
is any innovation and to evaluate at a
select kanika I know that you really
Express strong statement in terms of
artistic outcomes so how do you deal
with this notion of innovation or
something yet you take a bit on the side
or I guess we we take the stand that
innovation comes from the process and
from the communication and it's
something that needs to grow and not
something that you can force there in
into something so we don't I guess you
can't say we want the piece of
innovation you say okay I will bring
these people in a communication together
and see what the process brings and
usually what what mindset of the artists
they it's something that they have in
mind
and being a part of them or of course
they're very curious I mean they
wouldn't apply for such programs if they
weren't inherently interested in us for
instance at certain or in in astronomy
with the space agency so I think I think
the the artists are extremely curious
also of course the institution's they
also want to find out something new or
see if this process can instigate
something that wasn't there before that
they hadn't been aware of
lalla we spoke I have heard two words
one is co-creation and usually when we
do co-creation it's something that we do
together and also quite often also hear
the word here intervention using
intervention on artists is something
coming at one specific point in the
project and it's nuts the same as
co-creation and it seems that you have
kind of contradiction between these two
with how do you see it in practice at
your Center interesting we have a
co-creation studio actually in the
program called the oaken open
documentary lab and they've just written
a major study of co-creation it's called
collective wisdoms the title of it and
so they have looked at various practices
I think co-creation is defined by
duration and it's defined by frankly a
kind of democratic structure among the
participants and it is very much an
iterative process which may be different
from that sort of provocative
intervention that I just gave in the in
the previous example I think more and
more people are interested in this it's
going to be interesting to see how the
art world the art world with the capital
a adapts to that because it is so
fixated on authorship even though for
you know hundreds of years artistic
production has been collective and is
collective but the market has generated
that sense of authorship so I think the
interesting thing about co-creation
models is that it can also really change
the language the reception and maybe
even eventually the market within the
art world we'll see I think this notion
of authorship we had a discussion with
Daniella Cynthia de yesterday and said
that we should create a first framework
so that it creates an easy relation
between the different pointers because
someone's blocked at the beginning
because of this notion authorship
I being all it's calming things and I
should just say that collective wisdom
report is available free online if you
just google it it's I can't remember the
website but collective wisdom cannot you
what do you think it's more electronic
and the residency that you follow
intervention or really cooperation
between this discipline is between the
scientist and the artist it's really
hard to say we've had both so there's
there have been intense relationships
built between scientists and artists
working together and not so extremely
often that scientists actually went to
visit the artists in their studios but
then there's been like punctual I
remember at CERN there was this point
where they just had completely
spontaneous meet up with the scientists
and did something crazy but I don't know
what moved to something which is I think
unbalance between usually the artists
and and the the scientists is the
production of knowledge because when we
see usually a project you have the
scientists in their process and the rent
they get usually have the time to get an
honest state of the art to understand
what has been done before to make Riyadh
it artefacts on a real prototypes they
call it prototypes then to see the
observe the impact and it's something
which is normal were the artists it's
often where it's more an intervention he
produced his artwork which bring his
freedom but then it doesn't he's not
allowed to put you so so there's
knowledge which at the end when we're
doing innovation it's an imbalance
relation because one is reproducing the
knowledge the other bring a new vision
but doesn't have this knowledge how do
you deal this is this is a concern or
something that has been
Oh for us while talking all the time
about Co creations but sometimes it's
not really co-creation there's some kind
of there are some example where there's
it's unbalanced but sometimes when it's
door like not the perfect relationship
when you can observe something there as
I told you they they they wanted to
publish together and so it's very
interesting because they ask me where I
can publish because for science it's
it's really easy to to to you know where
you can publish is on publication on is
newspapers and further artist is
something different but what I can see
with the evolutions is that they wanted
to they want to publish together and
that's for me equation of knowledge and
new knowledge and to make contents about
the processes okay even at the cast you
have also got a co publication or is it
something that is done well we address
it in different ways I mean first of all
I would say that while I respect that
and have also seen that that there's the
desire to co publish it and if I can
just speak from personal experience with
the Saracino project actually it was
pretty interesting because the lab I
spoke of has generated several papers
and they want to put everybody on as
authors including Tomas and you know the
musicians that work on it and artists
sometimes can be forgetful about that in
odd ways about giving credit but I also
think that you know say with the the
project that I show that I was
personally involved in the arachnoid
Rome I at least speaking for me and the
other artists we weren't so interested
in knowledge we were just interested in
doing art and I didn't really I don't
can't say that I learned anything
necessarily about spiders from
improvising with the spiders or making
that piece but I I made some art that I
was you know absorbed in and learned
something about
my art in that way right but meanwhile
you know our collaborator Isabel needed
to publish a paper so she needed to
generate a different kind of knowledge
and I think that that's okay that you
have different kinds of outcomes that
are you know have their own pace and
have their own trajectory and have you
know have their own measure of of
whether it's been worthwhile however
with some of our projects we've been
very concerned with publication I should
let Lilith speak about that because
we've tried to address that pretty
directly with with the two books that we
put out so maybe you want to talk about
that yeah we after these symposia that
we do where we take an area deep or
emerging research at MIT the first one
was brain and cogs eye and the arts the
second one was material sciences and the
arts and we sort of put artists
humanists scientists and engineers into
the conversation and then we do big
collective publications as well as you
know online extensions of those and most
recently we also try to make the books
themselves multi-dimensional in a way so
the recent being material publication
has an online component as well as it's
a book you know and in addition it has
an a kind of interactive cover that
generates music you have to explain how
you did that but you can scan it with a
phone and it has so it's it's an object
we wanted something that was both
digital and material so the object
itself tries to embody this
multidisciplinary group of people that
created the knowledge of various kinds
and we try to put it out in various
platforms but this is one of the very
beautiful things about these
collaborations that there is the need to
find new or our very different forms of
presentation of outcomes so to say you
have books you have websites you have
maybe people building labs to mount an
exhibition or completely new forms of
presentation nicolai you know what sort
of new forms that you see occurring
because on your platter
you see a lot of different projects
different actors from the industry from
the arts from the design side what was
the outcome has it expressed and how do
you see what's the most promising for
Matt or diversity or format yeah because
we are not that kind of in it's like the
University let's say University field
where we have to publish papers or or or
kind of what we what we normally do
that's why I like kind of this tool box
you know is to really do custom eight
residents and project and then you can
also decide that there is no that's also
okay if both partners are okay with it
I also I like a lot but you explained
before with this exploit Toria T
exploratory now I got it
thank you so yeah that I think it's
really important that we give also a bit
of time to the artist and also to the
company to know each other or to the to
the university partners or if you work
in with the festival and then that it
comes kind of naturally out of an
interest and then you can also adapt in
advance somehow these expectations or
these outcomes yeah I think this is
really important to really keep it
flexible but normally yeah we don't
publish books it can be a performance it
can be an exhibition it can be just a
knowledge transfer it can be a good time
yeah there are a lot of outcomes if it's
already know that transfer it's already
good at something happens but we have
this rhiness mapping of a different
format of the other resonances and we
see here that some of them
really to produce new forms of art peace
Bazin what technology offers some are
more driven towards bomb ayam
innovations of producing something that
matters for a large audience and may be
influencing the daily life what when you
have the company's coming your place do
they reinstate this diversity of author
isn't it because wanna speak to big
manager often they see just this as a
big jerk or big ass off and they don't
understand this different type ology of
resonances and so not about the types so
for us it's not an issue because we come
to us they have an ignition of initial
question usually we've changed the
question over time but we just start to
work together and there's no name for it
and only when we had an intervention or
some things happened then we on
hindsight we can say this was an
artistic intervention but if I would use
to work in intervention or residency I I
think they would just back off because
they wouldn't understand so we just have
a common goal and the goal can be very
fake or very clear and this is what we
work on something will open so yeah yeah
question to the audience
can you give examples of positive
outcomes for companies in this process
of innovation involving artists and this
is for all of you Sandra I was so moved
when you talked in Spain about the
example of the company that wanted
support doing innovation and the artists
who went in and checked the context in
which innovation was stopped where so
happened maybe that would be a way of
even addressing what is the capacity for
innovation that needs to be prepared by
the artists
okay so we came in contact with this big
accountancy firm we will not name it but
it's all over the world and the question
was came from the innovation director
head of innovations and he after talking
for an hour we we found out that what
they need it would be artistic fire
which is awesome
if you're going out of a conversation
and the company wants artistic fire
because we have a lot of that because he
would he thought this would actually
enlarge the innovation capacity of the
company and then the artist came in and
and talked with a lot of people looked
around and he saw that all these people
are very creative in their own way
and there are really nice people very
intelligent but they were all like they
had they had this this layer over them
which prevented them from being in real
contact with their clients and if you're
not in real contact with your clients or
with your colleagues it is impossible to
go for innovation so he addressed this
this this layer that was underneath and
we developed a program into the light
which is now followed by 700 employees
of stepping into the light with your
personal story and connecting through
these stories and then
one of you said about how do you connect
the different parts of your University
and this is what's happening now in the
company because people find each other
on a personal level and that will make
the step to innovation or to change you
to new products or whatever way easier
so it's it's yeah it's a question maybe
to Helen and even and Leila and just to
understand how does it work within the
universities or academic institutions
what was the who was the initiator of
this project or program or or I mean has
it started from the university itself
was it your initiative there there were
two two conditions in 2014 it there
there is the merging of the university
historically there's four universities
in bottle and three of them merge
together so we had new policies and we
have I have to say that the Otton
Science program depends on innovation
policies and cultural policies because
we have a festival as well so in 2014
there's this first condition and the
other one is about fundings because we
had these big investment plans in France
I call it X which is a huge program to
develop internal internationalization
partnerships relations with companies
and actually there are 10 times probably
a small and small support program inside
this huge plan but I mean there is
dispersed things but it's a political
choice as well so
yeah it was a paper lunch we were in
charge at that moment it's interesting
that you mentioned it festival well as
Evan said MIT has this tradition of
putting art scientists and so that
existed going back to the Center for
Advanced visual studies but there was a
festival of art science and technology
that was created in 2011 for our 150th
anniversary of the founding of MIT and
after that happened where we just kind
of curated the campus it was an entire
semester of events that was
multidisciplinary in various ways we
said okay how can we create an
infrastructure to support this and
that's where we came up with the idea of
the center and we went to the mellon
Foundation which gave us a large grant
and then we pooled a lot of resources
that we had already at MIT but I wanted
to say something about Helen said she
was a matchmaker and we talked about
these exploratory visits and we often
call them speed-dating when and it
occurred to me that you could have
exploratory visits within the company
which is can be in especially big
companies as complex and siloed as
universities so it is about that sort of
catalyzing relationships among
individuals I think that's really
important and we crowdsource a lot of
our projects as Evan said you know
anyone can apply to twice a year so it's
coming from people who already want to
do something so I think that's very
important to ask what artists what
project do you want to work on and you
then it comes in and you do the true
then you do the curatorial work so I
wanted to respond to Helens question
about publications so we actually
published quite a few publications both
in print and online some are by
subscriptions some are free and most of
them are done through MIT press so if
you go to Leonarda info slash
publications you can find different ways
in which a lot of these collaborations
and
can benefit all the scientists and
engineers and all their author names and
are accredited in that in that
recognized through scholarly pipelines
which is really beneficial for anyone
who has to go into that format and I
also want to respond to some of the
knees for the way that a lot of emerging
technology needs to get out there and be
published we are launching in the next
within this year some experimental
platforms for how to publish work around
emerging technologies in new media in
very collaborative ways and create
interesting pipelines and how to do that
we can talk about that at another time
but one of the things that we've been
doing is listening very carefully to you
and everybody around the world the
question there the and in understanding
what the needs are from this community
the needs have been a raw around moat a
modal multimedia publications so not
being not just having something that is
written in print or in four corners but
is more immersive and interactive where
we are responding to that something
that's more collaborative and that has
accreditation to everybody that's
involved and allows for more
transparency in the review process we're
we're responding to that and we also
don't believe that the best ideas are in
English so we're publishing this year in
Chinese and hopefully in Spanish by the
beginning of next year and we believe
that we should create these platforms
that should be in any language that the
ideas are generated in they don't have
to be necessarily in English so I think
that we're looking at these residences
all over the world and the way that
these are collaborations are occurring
we also have to think about how do we
actually make sure these ideas are
disseminated and elevated in a credible
way in a thoughtful way in a way that
supports the community and really is a
way that we can all connect together and
this is where Leonardo I know has been
really thinking forward and how we can
respond
to everyone's needs in this process so
thank you for the remark last question
from the audience I have a question
about potential methodologies that can
emerge from processes of co-creation so
a lot has been said about what happens
you know in these fantastic interactions
between artists and researchers and
scientists and so forth is there any
effort that any of you are doing within
your spheres of actually registering
actually thinking through what what
methodologies how these can be recorded
somewhere and then potentially used or
be reused by researchers or academics
themselves on one hand on the other hand
may be looking at interventions and
observing these interventions so beyond
the co-creation process and and what
happens there - is there an experience
for example is there discursive relation
that can be established and what happens
with all this so so very interesting in
the moment but how what stays and from
an academic perspective is there any
hope in methodologies pedagogy and so
forth well I'm the discursive level I
mean I it's funny we were just saying
the other day that it would be
interesting to have sociologists observe
dragging all these resonances and that
that now we just have to find a
sociologist wants to do it but we try
very hard to document pretty
methodically we on all sorts of levels
they as as you can see we we share an
inclination toward the narrative and I
think that's reflected in in the way we
document and the types of documentation
we encourage but you know we put out a
booklet every year that describes all
the projects and not just the outcomes
but
the process itself it's not it is not
methodical it's it's discursive I mean
it's it's really just okay here's what
happened here and it's really from the
perspective whenever we get the writer
involved in observing and talking to
people but we do make an attempt to keep
track of everything that's happened yes
there is in that collective wisdom study
there are examples of methodologies
there examples of contracts among
participants there's a lot of good
material in that and if I could follow
up on the MIT press ting there's one of
the things I don't know if you were
talking about are teka by any chance
this is an online platform where the MIT
press is trying to capture I don't like
this word but they call it grey
literature so some of these residences
it might not go into a you know a
peer-reviewed journal or so forth they
may be processed documents they may be
dialogues or so forth and so it's a way
to publish online this kind of sort of
liminal I guess I would say in the world
of publication accounts of these
processes so there might be something to
look into as well yeah so underline that
there is several publication ran Diane
has done several also did one with
storage and we hope also that the
material coming from start residency can
be studied by others to create because
we have a lot of documentation and this
I think this is also for people who are
interested to work with this material
and study a bit more this relation we're
having funny to close the dancer so
we'll make a last round here and just
make one remark just to provoke that
your last sentence here you know in
science we observe on the campus the EPF
about 2000 PhD and the campus is quite
WOD company I think that often people
say oh you have the pure scientists and
then you have the applauded scientists
working asking to register for the
companies and in fact when you really
look at the publications the outcome the
licensing thing it's wrong what we
witness is that you have the goods
and you have the average dentists and
the one who creates good science and
reduce Rupp dividers with a huge number
of publication and good publication
there's a produce a lot of startup
companies licensing and think so
Oh perhaps have your input than this
with the artist because often I feel
that in the arts there you have the pure
artists and then you have the I would
say direct your artist designer working
with the industry that's you know kind
of so the question that the perception
in artist hack and an artist's word on
the pure arts with a big a but also work
perhaps with the industry or where the
companies who say that yes we can
influence what comes in our daily life
in terms of innovation and and don't
leave this that was my first question
just to the engineers and the managers
[Laughter]
the beginning and whether we with it
with the seeds where we can reorient so
they impact in every way educational
Society seeding educational you told me
that it's something you poignant
conclusion yeah I'm not sure I
understood the question sorry the
education part of how we see the how we
train up the artists to to have this
impact also on innovation not only an
empowered well we are sort of fortunate
in that sense and that we have these
students who can do amazing technical
things but are also interested in the
creative process I mean it's very
surprising to everyone to know but you
know anywhere from sixty nine to 79
percent of students coming in to MIT in
the last decade have been active in the
arts in high school in some way and yet
they're also math wizards and everything
else so I think yes education so that
it's combining in the same person
and as Evan said not dividing in
compartment lysing their lives is
crucial for the future so that that's a
very good conclusion point because we're
talking about education just after now
we have just 20 minutes to take coffee
we are talking about fat a fertile space
and I think we can find trust in the in
the coffee session now and let's be back
here in 20 minutes for the education
session